c'est
paul est accro j'ai quatre balles de
ping-pong quatre billets de 50 euros on
va faire un jeu je vais être les jeter
si tu arrives à mettre une balle dans
l'évier avec ta tête c'est 50 euros par
balles mise dans l'évier pourquoi
pourquoi
nonsard compte six a atterri même
s'arrondit tant que ça à terry deux ans
et comptait 50 euros exactement basile
valence
ok 50 euros peugeot
n'ont raté
au caire a dit
non mollo celle là toujours à 50 tu es
prêt pour la dernière ta chance de
gagner 100 euros là
c'est que 50
noms là bonjour
m
l'équation
ding dong
c'est
vous
pourquoi tu réponds pas un téléphone
donc ses cliques et là dans
ces activités
[Musique]
manger sainement aller à la seule
arrivée la fac à l'aider la fraq arrêté
la femme
allaiter la favela pas arrêter la phase
aller dès la fin
de la merde